hi everyone thanks for joining we're
going to get started now today we have
dr moore here so i'll turn it over to
him for some brief remarks
good afternoon bon appetit
it's been a little over two years since
ontario reported its first case of covet
19.
and in these two years we have fought to
reduce transmission
of this virus and minimize its severe
outcomes
such as hospitalization and death
we have seen the way we live work and
socialize change
the public health measures that have
been implemented have been necessary and
have saved lives
and they have come at a cost to our
mental health our well-being and our
livelihoods
i want to thank ontarians for their
sacrifices
i know it has not been easy
while we know covert 19 is not going
away we are in a very different place
than we were two years ago we have
greater knowledge and experience in how
this virus behaves and what
works to stop its transmission
we have tools that we have not had
before we have highly effective vaccines
that have changed the course of this
pandemic and we have effective
treatments for those at risk of getting
very sick
our vaccination rates are amongst the
best in the world with over 90 percent
of ontarians age 12 and over with two
doses we continue to make progress in
our vaccination campaign for our five to
11 year olds 54
have one dose and over 24 percent have
two doses
in over 6.7 million ontarians have
received their booster dose
many
of you heard the call for arms by
rolling up your sleeves you have not
only protected yourselves from serious
illness and hospitalization you have
also helped our dedicated front-line
health care providers by reducing the
burden on our health care system
while the risk remains this commitment
has paid off and means that we can
continue to ease some of the public
health restrictions today and again on
march 1st
hospitalization
easing measures allows our society to
start enjoying the things that improve
our well-being
but it also means continuing with
ontario's staged
phased cautious and evidence-based
approach
this includes keeping our mass on a
while longer and that health and safety
plans are in place to keep public spaces
safe for all of us
as we move forward covid 19 vaccines
continue to remain a cornerstone of our
plan to manage this virus
as of 8 am tomorrow february 18th
ontario is expanding booster dose
eligibility to youth age 12 to 17.
appointments can be booked through the
provincial booking system and provincial
vaccine contact center as well as
pharmacies administering the pfizer
vaccine
ontario
rendezvous
appointments can be booked for six
months or 168 days after a second dose
boosters are an effective means of
reducing your likelihood of becoming
seriously ill from covet 19.
there's also now good evidence that
vaccination cuts your risk of developing
long covet syndrome in half
even if you have had covid in the past
getting vaccinated is still recommended
as it provides better protection against
future infection and it's never too late
to get vaccinated with your first second
or booster dose
we have in observed continued
improvements in stabilization and key
public health and health system
indicators the percent positivity
continues to decrease and new admissions
to hospital and icu have been declining
week over week
these are there are also continued
decreases in the number of outbreaks in
high risk settings such as hospitals and
long-term care homes once again i want
to thank ontarians for their incredible
sacrifices your collective efforts have
allowed us to get back
to where we are today
our plan to get here has always been
data driven and the decisions that we
make will continue to be based on the
best science and evidence
the risk remains
and we remi must remain nimble in our
response and be ready to respond to new
risks in a manner that minimizes severe
outcomes in impacts on our health system
while limiting any further disruption
of every person's daily lives thank you
merci
go to the phone lines for questions just
a reminder it's one question one
follow-up over to the first question
please
your first question comes from richard
southern with city news 680 please go
ahead
hi dr moore thanks for taking my
question doctor aside from yourself
ontarians have turned to the premier for
advice on what to do during the pandemic
this past tuesday the premier suggested
there was little value in further rounds
of vaccination without pointing out that
it reduced hospitalizations the premier
said quote we also know that it doesn't
matter if you have one shot or 10 shots
you can still catch covet 19. doctor do
you think that comment was appropriate
coming from the premier well i can
understand his concern and it's about
the protection of the vaccine against
transmission and it has been excellent
against all the original strains against
of covid so alpha beta gamma delta it's
less effective against omicron against
transmission the good news is for this
vaccine that the protection is excellent
against severe outcomes
and i think that is what really needs to
get highlighted
a third dose is over 90 percent
effective against admission to hospital
admission to the intensive care unit and
or death two doses is still excellent
but three doses are better two doses is
around 80 percent effective against
severe outcomes hospitalization icu and
death so i think that's the story that
really needs to get told yes
the vaccine with three doses around 60
percent protective against getting
symptomatic covid19 disease
but it's excellent against the severe
outcomes
follow-up
as we begin to loosen some restrictions
today we're learning that a wastewater
analysis shows that the reduction in
cases has plateaued
can you speak to that and does that give
you any concern right now doctor
no i mean i think that's excellent news
if you look at the epidemic curve of
that data it really shows we've reached
our peak several weeks ago
and that correlates to our
rise in admissions to hospital which
peaked in the third week of january and
they've been coming down ever since so
yes they're plateauing
but they're plateauing at a very low
level
and hence i do think that the the peak
and risk and the peak inactivity of
omicron is behind us there remains a
risk there remains a risk of
transmission every day and hence the
need to continue to wear our mass at
present but we'll we'll review the
evidence of when we can further reduce
that public health measure of masking in
public spaces
and everyone should make a risk
assessment especially if you're
vulnerable to this virus if you're
elderly or immune suppressed
please continue to come forward and get
vaccinated as it protects against all
the severe outcomes but
i think the worst is behind us but there
is an ongoing risk i don't think uh and
and i've had conversations with those
experts from the science table will have
a significant rebound in activity or
impact on our health care system i do
think the worst is behind us
next question
your next question comes from charlie
pinkerton with queen's park briefing
please go ahead
good afternoon uh dr moore um
as part of the government's plan to end
its mandatory proof vaccination system
on
um march the 1st i'm of the
understanding that
the vaccine mandates and soft vaccine
mandates for
other professions
will continue
have you begun thinking about when these
should be ended
um and you know if so could you sort of
explain your where you currently stand
um on on these requirements
well thanks very much for that question
yes we're reviewing all directives and
letters of instruction that we put in
place
across multiple sectors in ontario
we do
think the the highest risk is behind us
that we're heading into a lower risk
environment
and that the need
for
vaccination policies
across ontario
sectors whether it's health or in
colleges and universities uh is no
longer necessary so we've started those
conversations just in the last couple of
days of when we will remove the
immunization policy requirement for
colleges and universities for other
workplace settings as well as in the
healthcare system i do think we should
align their removal with the removal at
a population level so on march 1st
that may be early for some organizations
but that's my goal is to have those
immunization policies removed by the
first they have done their uh their
intended purpose was to improve
immunization to further protect
ontarians i thank all ontarians that
have come forward to get vaccinated
but they have served their purpose to
protect us
and as any public health measure they
have to be removed in a timely manner
follow-up
yeah sorry sorry am i following you
correctly then that these other again
what i'd ask about the the other vaccine
mandates for
professions essentially um
that they could be gone as soon as march
1st
and then just on top of that
you know various public health measures
have come and gone during the pandemic
of course
um
once the proof vaccination system goes
away being
likely the you know most significant
more one of the most significant
measures brought to date
um by the government
do you ever see yourself recommending it
return or or is that it for this system
so i just want to make sure we're on the
same page we we have not mandated
immunizations we have mandated that
organizations have immunization policies
so that's typically uh get immunized get
educated regarding the benefits and
risks of the vaccine and or have a
testing strategy so that recommend that
mandate to have an immunization policy
will uh it's my intent together with
negotiation with partners to have them
removed by march 1st
and
i think that's prudent it follows the
removal of proof of immunization
for other venues so
i think it's timely to remove them for
businesses it there may be mandates uh
by organizations that are
not government
that would want to have a testing
strategy uh continue especially if they
have a high risk uh setting uh and i'll
just also be particular that the that
there was a mandate uh for vaccination
in long-term care facilities by the
minister
that is separate as it wasn't a
directive by
by the chief medical officer health
office
next question
your next question comes from holly
mackenzie suiter with the canadian press
please go ahead
hi dr moore i want to talk about the the
pace of the reopening plan the latest
version had
21 days between each step and you've
said repeatedly that's a good and
cautious way to monitor the impacts of
each step but now we're less than two
weeks away before all capacity limits
and the vaccine certificates end we're
not going to have that much time to
monitor the impacts of the changes today
so i could just explain what the rush is
with this especially looking at the the
wastewater data
wastewater data has come down
significantly so
we we are now if you recall we put
public health measures in on january 5th
we then opened schools on the 17th so
there was roughly you know 12 12 day
separation uh we then further opened the
economy again on the 31st um so another
two week separation we then made a
17-day separation so we're always
following the data and the science i'm
just so pleased
that our hospitalization rates are
coming down very rapidly they went up
rapidly and and now they're coming down
in a very quick descent and remembering
hospitalization is a later signal
so i do think the risk is less at a
population level i i do think we're the
worst is behind us uh and i think
following the data
any public health measure should be as
short as possible it limits people's
freedoms and rights and we have to be
responsive uh to to that and the
implications of public health measures
so we've always said that they should be
proportionate to the risk and balanced
in their response
and i think uh
shortening it by three to four days this
time from the 21st to the 17th was
reasonable uh and and because we're
having such a rapid descent and i do
anticipate that we won't have any
significant rebound in risk
to hospitalization that we can continue
at a two-week march
to march first
to open up more broadly
follow-up
yeah i'm just learning as well about um
you know last year we lifted
restrictions at around this time with a
plan to
not enforce them province wide again and
then in a couple months we had a hard
lockdown basically in april because of
the pressures on the health system
and i know you said you know we have
vaccines now things are different but
what's the plan in the event that there
is a new new variant that strains the
health system again like the unexpected
can happen as we know so
what is the the backup plan would
restrictions have been brought back or
are we looking regionally or kind of
what
um yeah can you just explain more the
thinking of kind of if things don't go
the way we want or these trends don't
continue
well i am optimistic um that we're on
the right path uh and want to thank all
ontarians for the sacrifices they've
made uh you're absolutely right we're in
a much better position now with 90 of
our 12 and up population having had at
least two doses 6.7 million ontarians
having had three doses and now having
wide availability of other therapeutics
including outpatient oral treatments
much better position now
i
absolutely don't want to have to go back
and
and impose any public health measures
you're basically asking are we ready if
there's a new variant we've got a very
robust surveillance system we can
expand our pcr testing capacity if
necessary
to try to deal with a new strain or
variant um we've got plenty of public
health experience and health system
infrastructure now in place more icu
beds more treatment
options for patients so i think we're in
a much better position now i also think
internationally we have more people
immunized at an international level we
still have a long ways to go
at least 40 percent more of the global
population
should get
access to vaccines and that's an
international effort once we get that
the risk of new variants emerging
should decrease
but we have a robust surveillance system
both provincially and nationally i trust
our public health agency of canada to be
monitoring the international scene as
well for any new variants and to be able
to put in travel restrictions if and
when necessary
we've learned plenty in the last two
years of how how to reduce the risk
and i think the science behind this is
much better than we've ever had
last question unless someone else joins
the queue
your next question comes from jeff gray
with the globe and mail please go ahead
oh hi dr moore i just wanted to ask
about the timeline for
for lifting masks
you know you've mentioned i guess the
two-week period between
restrictions that when they're lifted
and so on to see for the impacts i think
you've mentioned also a
possible level of
10 a rate of 10
per 100 000 in infections can you is
there a criteria on when you would look
at lifting masks and would you do it
across the board or would we leave them
in schools and on transit and hospitals
or can you talk a bit more about when
that's coming and what it'll look like
well thanks very much it's a great
question jeff and we're actively working
on that we want to open up on the 17th
and make sure that that's done safely
further opening on the first and monitor
the data as we've done in a phased
staged approach it's worked well for us
in ontario
and two weeks after that we review any
other public health measures including
masking
if
if and when we transitioned it would be
from you know a mandate to mask to a
recommendation to mask i would certainly
hope that vulnerable members of our
community that are at risk for this
virus that are immune suppressed or
transplant patients in public spaces
would continue to mask and we may review
uh masking for public spaces like uh
and transport systems like subways buses
etc to ensure that everyone's confident
to use those uh resources so if you'll
bear with us we're going to follow the
data follow the evidence
and anticipate that we'll be reviewing
uh pat masking in public on the second
to third week of of march
and make decisions for all
public spaces including schools
in that time frame
follow-up
uh so for schools and then what
malls and retail and so on but but um
it might possibly remain in certain
settings even after that time
but we absolutely want to look at the
risk at a population level
and
make sure that we're in a safe place
across ontario across all regions
because this will be removing it for all
ontarians and we know there are some
regional differences even right now you
know micron activity is higher in the
north and northeast so
but you have our assurance that we're
going to review all measures including
masking
and will make the removal at a
population level when it's the safest
time for ontarians but ensure that those
that are vulnerable feel confident to
continue to wear them uh to to best
protect themselves we all need a a break
from them um
but reminding ourselves that we may need
them again in the fall if omicron comes
back
and obviously all the other respiratory
viruses are going to want to come back
given we haven't been exposed for many
years against them
last question
your final question comes from randy
rast with chch tv please go ahead
yeah hi doctor um i'm wondering if
you're saying that
the
necessity for
vaccine mandates in workplaces is gone
on on march 1.
should people that were fired that lost
their employment because they refused to
get a a vaccination should they be
rehired
well i would leave that up to the
individual corporation
our policy and recommendation was to
have an immunization policy uh whether
you vaccinate or uh get tested uh if
they've gone forward and had a mandate
which was not our direction
i would leave it up to the individual
corporation to negotiate that with their
workforce
follow-up and this is the last question
would you doctor feel confident
that
an unvaccinated person
could go and work in a long-term care
facility now
well it's a good question i i think
we've improved the infection prevention
and control practices uh significantly
in long-term care
i think as we head to low endemicity
and low-risk environments in that
setting we should absolutely review
all
measures that have been put in play
but
infection prevention control practices
so masking and hand hygiene
all those
practices that work so well before we
have vaccine have to be
monitored you need good quality
assurance that they're maintained and
the workforce is educated in them
realize their benefit
and i think that's one of the biggest
lessons learned from
our long-term care activities is how to
ensure ongoing sustained
benefit of the baseline infection
prevention control practices to best
protect their clientele
thanks everyone